je l'assumé amplement ça a été un
mariage forcé sous la manipulation en
fait quand mon père m'a dit ben tu je
serais tellement fière de toi si tu te
maries je serais tellement tu seras la
meilleure de mes filles tu seras tu va
remonter l'honneur de la famille j'ai
dit ok allez on y va et bien sûr et bien
sûr papa puis je ferai tout pour toi à
moi
[Musique]
moi je suis content pour eux et bah
parce que voilà je suis heureux belge
fait mes choix de vie je n'accepte pas
l'injustice
mariage forcé ensuite divorce sont pas
de ces petits salubre huit mois c'est à
shirani et aujourd'hui je vais te
raconter mon histoire
[Musique]
mes parents sont originaires du pakistan
plus exactement je suis né dans un petit
village qui s'appelle koundjia je suis
arrivé en france quand j'avais huit mois
mes parents ont quitté le pays et du
coup après je suis resté en france j'ai
grandi en france et j'ai développé en
fait bah mon autre une autre culture à
travers la culture française à l'école
je me sentais bien à l'école c'était un
peu mon échappatoire ça se passait pas
très bien à la maison et ce qui fait que
ben en fait quand j'allais à l'école
bah voilà j'avais besoin de rigoler j'ai
besoin de souris et j'avais besoin de
courir de partout en fait on a grandi
avec
la uniquement la culture pakistanaise
c'est à dire maman mes parents ne
parlait pas du tout français à la maison
on parlait tous holdouts pendjabi est ce
qui fait que bahia au même au niveau de
la nourriture maman ne cuisinait
absolument jamais une cuisine française
elle ne connaissait pas elle ne savait
pas du coup vraiment on était né
totalement battu franchissait le seuil
de la porte et tu te retrouves et au
pakistan
[Musique]
un
jour en étant en lice aimons le cpe
voilà je me suis plaint de grosses
migraines j'arrivais pas à suivre les
cours et du coup ben j'avais insisté
pour qu il les appelle pas par sécurité
il a quand même appelé mon père mon père
est venu à l'école en furie énervé parce
que j'avais perdu son temps donc je sors
du lycée et
là bas j'ai un camarade du lycée en fait
il me dit quoique chan et la mode
british suite
moi je savais que ça allait pas passer
mais lui il savait pas pour lui c'est
normal en fait y'a un tchad on l'appelle
quoi et là bas je savais que ça allait
me tomber dessus dix mètres plus loin on
perd c'est qui lui c'est qui lui pour
rappel c'est pour ça que tu vas à
l'école on sait que tu vas aller
correspond pas aller au garçon tu vas à
l'école ah ouais d'accord ouais ce sens
c'est pour ça que je vais emmener en
france 1 1 c'est ça vous voulez la
liberté vous voulez hein voilà le mot
liberté
j'aime à torturer l'esprit ce mot
enfants du collège en fait mais j'ai
commencé à travailler en fait à aider
mon papa au commerce dans les commerces
et là c'était la descente aux enfers un
petit peu en fait parce que bah j'ai eu
d'abord raté mon brevet parce que ben
justement je n'avais pas le temps de
réviser après j'ai réussi à le repasser
donc j'ai été jusqu'au lycée mais
l'appareil j'ai galéré
[Musique]
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ils n'ont jamais
accepté la danse ça a toujours été une
honte auprès d'eux auprès de mes parents
auprès de mon père et de ma mère et mes
frères et soeurs quoi
[Musique]
je suis partie au pakistan en vacances
ensemble vacances arrivé là-bas mais
tente du côté de volontaires ont été
envoyés en mission telle te manipule
d'une certaine manière pour que tu
arrives à dire oui en fait donc au début
tu dis non et en fait de fil en aiguille
ben tu fini par dire ok ok je veux ok je
rencontre je rencontre la personne par
exemple une personne qui se présente
après ils te disent ok mais du coup ce
serait bien tu te que tu fasses un
fiançailles
ok on fait les fiançailles mais rien
d'autre un oui d'accord ensuite hockey
est ce que ça te dit directement qu'on
fasse le mariage parce que comme ça moi
c'est fait t'as pas à revenir avec ta
famille ces faits n'ont du coup un tac
tac tac tac désir que ça il va vraiment
étape par étape et enfin battu fini par
dire oui ça a été très très très vite
les préparations
les achats des vêtements les décorations
la location de la salle tout tout tout
tout en quinze jours c'était tout bouclé
et on qu'un jour je me suis retrouvé
marier avec un homme que ce que je
connaissais pas
[Musique]
hamon
a lille a fait du chantage mais elle m'a
dit moi écoute je sais pas qui tu étais
avant le mariage je te connais pas je
sais pas quel genre de fille qui était
avant le mariage donc moi la prochaine
fois que tu viendras la tua mesuré sur
le courant que t'as pas fait si t'as pas
fait ça t'a pas grave ou là là là moi
j'ai la mentalité française ma force
européenne qui est ressorti judy écoute
ça c'est peut-être au pakistan en tout
cas moi je ne fais pas prôner cette
mentalité là en france c'est pas comme
ça donc next et là ça a été un nouveau
combat un nouveau combat pour moi parce
que bah il fallait affronter la famille
avec le divorce et ça c'était juste pas
possible en fait donc on ne divorce pas
chez nous c'est la honte des divorcés
dans notre culture
[Musique]
regarde je suis mariée depuis novembre
mes parents non mariés à 17 ans en
manipulant comme tu l'avais raconté dans
son histoire il me parlait de l'honneur
de la famille le pire c'est qu'ils m'ont
marié à mon cousin tu vois en fait ils
font beaucoup ça aussi nous mariano
propre cousin des fois des gens avec qui
on a grandi en fait tu vois moi je vais
cette force auprès de ces personnes là
en leur disant
ce n'est pas normal
vous n'avez pas l'obligation de dire oui
vous avez le droit de dire non et ce
n'est pas parce que vous allez dire non
que vous allez être des mauvaises
enfants que vous allez manquer de
respect à vos parents pas du tout vous
allez vous que manquer de respect à vous
même si vous dites oui d'accord je finis
par marié donc c'est vraiment cette
force c'est ce message que je veux
apporter en vous disant soyez forts
battez vous et quitte à ce que oui c'est
vrai ça va peut-être couper des liens
oui c'est vrai qu'elle va peut-être être
dur pour vous pour vivre quelques temps
mais au moins vous allez respecter votre
vie à vous comment vous allez vivre
[Musique]